hello guys my name is a China and
welcome to another episode of this
genesis series so we're taking a look at
one of the first games I've ever made
and seeing what we can do to fix some of
the problems and just you know going
over the card having fun with it and
stuff like that so last time we took a
look at the lighting engine
quote-unquote so to speak and let my
continue button again and yeah I mean we
we talked about
I must have spelled the time as well we
talked about how these lighting tiles
actually work and then this episode I
said that I would talk about how the mob
lighting was right because what happens
is as a mob approaches a light as you'll
see in a minute the mom kind of gets
lighter right and you can kind of see
that happening here there is a bit of a
bug with it where it doesn't actually
happen all the time
it should there you can see that it's
not a lot yeah like for example I'm
still lit here for some reason there's
something we need to talk about but
anyway how does this system even work in
the first place that's what we're gonna
answer today Minna excuse me I mean I
have no idea right now so we're gonna
want to learn this together if I can
stop coughing so step one here's going
to be to take a look at how mom's are
rendered in the first place so it's I
mean I can I can already kind of see
this in my head because every game that
I make is a fairly similar but I believe
we should have a function here that
renders mobs and then every mobile
probably have its own right in the
function so take a look at this we have
entities to render so every entity class
has a render function which as far as
the hierarchy goes we have mob which
extends entity so that has its own
render function as well I mean this
one's not any different then then then
the other one but I did just find a
function called render lighting which
looks promising
and then if we go to say player for
example I'm sure that the player will
have a render function oh wow
little these spawn female little these
functions
anyway this render and then render has
what we have in render we have our
animation stuff we have which sprite we
pick basically that's an awful way of
doing it but anyway we have screened or
random mob okay so that's in the screen
class and then we have render lighting
which takes in statically the live tiles
and render lighting is that function
that we found in mob so let's take a
look at this this happens for every
single mob I assume if we go to like
female something that we have render
lighting if we go into what are the
other ones called so let's see what we
have here and see mob so maybe like just
forest mob I think forest mob was
actually the the regular ones sprite
I'll play a three I have no idea anyway
yeah I mean they do this as well so
first of all it looks like we render the
mob independently from the lighting
which again is a bit weird if we take a
look at what player does we do render
mob which seems to actually render
seriously what is this anyway it was we
I think that was from actually one of
these episodes yeah it was weird
I'd remember that anyway um and then we
actually rendered this I mean it looks
like we do do lighting here though so
I'm not exactly sure like what that is
because you can see that we do the mob
dot light distance times level
brightness time is somewhere number and
then we actually do the change
brightness so I'm actually curious as to
what render light rendered lighting
actually does so let's take a look at it
because it is being called oh I see I
think we just work out the light
distance that's probably it
yeah because we pass in the light
distance right yeah mob don't like dist
okay so I'm learning a little bit here
so what seems to be happening
I'm just gonna have some water real
professional so what seems to be
happening is we seem to have be having
this is this should probably be the
other way around anyway so render
lighting actually seems to all all it
really seems to do is calculate this
field that we have called light distance
right and it does that with a few
different in a few different ways I mean
ultimately it it is a distance and then
it finally the distance is greater than
100 we end up with with negative one so
we go through this real quick so we have
a light size which is interesting value
and then what we do is we go through
every light tile on the entire map it
would look like or I think that list
gets dynamically generated actually
because that gets passed in from here
which is in live tile dot live tiles and
I believe that gets populated yeah
that's right it does get dynamically
generated I remember now
because we have live tiles all clear
yeah so the live tiles essentially get
padded but these are the level live
tiles not the light tiles inside live
tile I don't know what why we have to in
the first place but also called render
all but when we created it has it
statically anyway what hang on a minute
hi I'm slightly confused now how exactly
does that work
hold your horses how does that work
because when does that get cleared when
does this list get cleared the one
that's in live tile and why is it even
use I mean it's used for the hang on and
I think I may have just discovered that
why the bug is there I don't think that
gets cleared let's just let's just try
this for fun lights
tiles white tiles dot spies
okay so now it does get cleared what is
it what is it get cleared there oh and
it's also it's it's not the actual light
tiles it's just
yeah the torch tiles really okay so we
must be clearing on somewhere
let's just see what that's happening
it'll be cold like how do you search
global I think this not clear in the
game yeah there it is
okay cool so after we render level in
the game class we call light tile but
light also clear all right good
that's there okay fair enough
just net just have to make sure that
that was actually happening okay so then
we go through all of our live tiles we
calculates the okay so the live tile
position I assume then would be in terms
of tiles because what we're doing there
is we're multiplying it by 16 which will
take it up to be in pixels so basically
what this is is it's working out the
pixel boundaries of the actual tile that
the light is on so basically this would
be a bounding box essentially a bounding
box for the torch tile and then this is
figuring out the center X and center Y
as the name would imply it's gonna be
the center or the average of of course
the horizontal and vertical balance
which is the center of the tile and then
we have this wonderful code so what is
this entry being used for okay it's
later on after distance yeah that makes
sense okay so this not X so if this dot
X is greater than ah I see okay
so essentially what we're doing here or
what we should be doing here 48 by the
way is the product it's 16 times 3 okay
because a tile extends yes a tile a
light tile can cost can cost lies up to
3 tiles like you know in like a 3 Tarkan
our radius so you'll see here in a
minute we have we have to torch down
then one two three I guess that's what
that 48 is it's essentially you know
three times 16 so 48 pixels and we're
basically saying if this mob is within
that boundary yeah and then we can
actually work out the distance I guess
that it is from the light but I'm not
sure why that requires a full loop
exactly or two for loops for that matter
okay sure oh yeah this is this is uh
this is interesting this is interesting
okay so what are we
looping between oh my goodness
that's really advances so going through
every single pixel oh my goodness when
aren't even using it I'm shocked shocked
at this card goodness me I hope Java
optimized that by removing it goodness
me
that must have been a completely
different this is what happens when you
don't think so this part of the card is
completely unnecessary oh my goodness me
so let's rewrite this function quickly
it might even solve our bug I'm probably
important I mean it mine
so let's see what we don't need that so
let's let's do this let's add light
distance to be a negative one we have to
also remember by the way that we're
doing this for each light tile so the
light light distance negative one which
is set to be here we need to find a
better way to stay in shape would we
actually find the closest light tile
first because it's kind of you know this
case is connect and the user a because
if there are two lights that are
intersecting we want to get the closest
one anyway
but a better way to do that might be
something like this where we have let's
just say we're in the bounds right so we
need to do that check so we assigned
light distance and we need to quickly
check to see if it's we can do something
like if it's less than a hundred or to
keep it exactly the same less than equal
to a hundred that's when we actually
assign it so we have our distance I
think that's a double right as in now
light this was a double yep
so we have our distance and what if if
that distance falls into our ones are
accepted kind of parameters then we
actually assign it and I guess we would
also want to do the minimum of that
possibly so I mean this would work this
I believe this would do the same as what
this did right yeah because we override
it anyway so really it's whatever
I know wires whole thing fails oh no no
actually no that wouldn't cause that
would it because we have to be in the
balance for two count
but also a company with a hundred this
is a all a bit weird to be honest let's
just see what this gives us a foster
game is the first answer okay so there's
that whole notion of completely new
lighting which is okay for now
actually seems to work pretty well I
mean it's not definitely called any
problems here I'll see if we can breed a
little bit if I can find a woman come on
where are you at there you are
come here which I had that mini mount in
fact I can probably just enable it all
right so we're a female asked about
eight o'clock oh yeah all right two more
up there okay so this should be enough I
think for our experiment okay so there
we go so I mean she definitely did fade
in okay
let's see if there are need there was
still any bugs with flooding here at
least hang on I can't help myself
and that actually seems to work pretty
well and we do have that abrupt like
fade-out but yeah and he totally worked
yeah now looks pretty good to me
looks like that did fix it I mean we
didn't need to shoot up the radius and
stuff all right there you go
so yeah I mean morale the story is don't
write ridiculous code what is up with
that I just don't get I just don't get
it at all
I mean honestly this is how I would this
is how I would do this function if I if
I had to rewrite it properly actually so
first of all let's just be clear that
this is really supposed to be trial size
which I don't even think we have as a
constant but 16 times 3 so that we
actually know what that is still 100%
sure we actually need to have that but
anyway we're gonna first of all loop
through all those light tiles all right
which we can do using a for each loop
flat tile tile in these light tiles
which I call Delta not light tiles but
anyway so here's what we're doing we're
trying to find the minimum most light
tile so we have a live tile that we
actually have selected so we'll call
this lifestyle which is equal to null
we're gonna loop through all these tiles
we're going to get the distance of that
light tile all I mean we could work out
whether or not is essentially in the
bounds if we really wanted to so to do
that bounce jack again we're just going
to do that this of course gets replaced
with this
and this is if we still want to do the
balance check which we don't really have
to but I mean we can if we want we then
check to see if the mob is inside that
all right so if this dot X let's just
verify that that's all correct that
likes your yep okay that maths checks
out so we can basically just say that if
that's false that whole expression is
false we can continue on to the next
tile right otherwise if it's not false
how candidate kind of moves up so what
we do now is we check to see if light
owls know we can do a distance check as
well oh well actually this would mean
that the mob would actually be in the
balance which means that we do have to
actually do the light tile check I think
so we basically just found a live tile
right so a live tiles can equal tile
okay at this point if light tile is null
then we return there's nothing to do
okay we have we are not in light so we
stayed the same otherwise we do actually
have to apply lighting so we no longer
need this now all the bounds the center
X can stay and we'll sort it out in a
different way I think so the center of
the light is what we're interested in so
again we can just kind of do that check
here
maybe we should and the balance not
really interesting that we know what LX
1 is going to be anyway so we can just
basically do I mean all we really need
to do here to get the center of light
you just say light tile above X plus 8
okay or plus 16 divided by 220 plus a
that's going to be the center right we
don't need to do anything special we
know that's going to be the center again
I would do a tile that size divided by a
2 or whatever if I had that constant
somewhere but it doesn't look like I do
and then finally we don't need this
check anymore which is nice we just need
to work out the distance and update it
if we need to update it right so we
still use this on X which we can
actually just write as X
and this dot y as well we don't need to
do the absolute thing because we're
squaring the number anyway which means
that it will be positive in the end
finally we're screwed we're square
rooting yes so this is pretty pretty
pretty simple kind of Pythagoras theorem
to work out the distance now if the
distance is 100 and we and not updating
the distance otherwise we gave it as
negative 1
I might actually end up changing that
it's a good idea to set it as negative 1
all the time anyway because that way if
we do return as we do here it does it
like it it will get set to negative 1
which Biggers obviously that means that
we're not in life so we really only have
to work it out if there is a light but
yeah because of the distance to distance
a hundred might not be the best value to
actually set here before we we actually
managed to kind of smooth it out somehow
which is a bit not sure exactly how that
worked because it looks like a lot is
the same not sure but I mean if we take
a look at three tiles of 16 16 16 48 the
max distance that we can actually be
away from the light pushes the center
remember so if we pop up in a calculator
we have the 48 we have the 48 search
over here we have the 48 we have another
8 to get to the center right I'm
assuming that the exit tags from the mob
is also centered just assume it is okay
so it's essentially going to be 56 plus
56 or rather 56 squared plus 56 squared
and then the square root of that so we
can be a maximum of about 80 let's just
say so I'm not sure why that exactly
get set like that hmm 100 seems weird I
don't know I'm not sure that we actually
need that to be honest because after a
while it will be too too long anyway
let's just see what that looks like
I'll get rid of them out or shelf paper
okay so we do time block immediately
when we actually ant ah yeah I guess I
guess that's why no but hang on that
means that it's negative one right let's
go to player and let's just let's just
print the players I also don't like the
fact that we're doing this in Reverse
but anyway let's print the players light
distance and let's stop printing a light
tile size negative one yes the way
negative one and then when we enter a
light we get a value 800 hold on a
minute that's not right at all
what
more dawn
what what
oh no what I've done well yeah so this
needs to this isn't Isles no needs to
step up
whoops takes a while sometimes okay
today yeah I mean it's look not really
the smoothest transition here but that's
again that's to do with the fact that
our lighting curve is not really
accurate but in terms of being bug free
this should be completely perfect and it
also should be very very so you can see
that numbers we calculated there on a
calculate it was like 79 was the max or
something so you can see that yeah right
about there's the max we can actually
get away from it we can never be further
away than 80 yeah so we should be
completely bug free here again that
lightning keV does need a bit of an
adjustment I think we we calculate that
in screen probably where we check to say
this negative one when we actually
rented the mob lighting so yeah if it's
less than zero we set it to the level
brightness so maybe we can set it a
little bit brighter than that I don't
know exactly how bright I want it but if
we just set it a little bit brighter
just so it doesn't pop as much what is
it so anyway level brightness what is a
little brightness let's just up that a
bit Wow
right anyway you can kind of see what
I'm doing yeah oh but that's gonna
change isn't it yeah that's a bad idea
what I'm doing is that yeah that goes
with the brightness oh all right new
plan it's the only real new plan I can
possibly have is changing the curve of
the brightness to match that which would
mean that we'd be reduced to level
brightness and the way you could do that
is a few different ways first of all
we'd have to make sure that if color was
somehow below level brightness then we
made sure that it wasn't right so the
way we do that is when we decide to
change it which is a new color we'll
call it if this new color is the lower
I'll rather hang on I'm doing the wrong
thing we gab we get our intended
brightness which is this which is an
integer by the way we try and we first
of all check to see if this brightness
is below so if the if this brightness is
below level brightness then we basically
have to set brightness to be level
brightness okay so that way we can never
go darker with this and then after that
it's just gonna be a matter of changing
that curve right so that's almost
perfect
and there you go you know it's still a
bit of a pop maybe into hot st. day a
lot obviously you should be able to
watch the other mobs as well yeah you
can see that that this gives us a
perfectly smooth transition and
absolutely no pulp and that's kind of
the idea
yeah actually looks quite nice so there
yeah that's one way to do it and it
should be perfecto
yeah it's pretty good to me okay so
that's essentially how more blighting
works it's pretty simple all we do
essentially is we use a function to
calculate how bright a mob should be
based on its position in relation to a
light source and that's all we then
that's just going to be a value it's the
distance value and then when it comes
time to render the mob we change the
mobs brightness by darkening the pixels
if it's further away from the light
that's it it's very very simple we do
that for every mob as you can see and I
mean I rewrote this to be a little bit
less chaotic which probably greatly
increased our frame rate by the way we
can actually do a bit of a benchmark I
mean I don't know if it actually did
because I think that Java would strip
these for loops
it might not though so let's actually
give that a test it's a fun I want to
find that print line that I have what
would that be that was the yeah being
player okay so with the old method this
is the new method with the old method we
gasps yarda the mop-up all right let's
find the island this is gonna be a
benchmark really okay I'm actually just
gonna disable every single level except
for the one that I I don't even know how
to do this where is the play button that
all the play equals true oh that's right
it's not even a function it's just a
state so weird I really hate that yeah
play play my new biome is is is correct
so where is that referenced
oh that's when it changes I don't even
know where this is I actually don't know
where this is well that looks promising
what's this you get to the hole select
which map you want to play on that's not
that's not true oh there used to be a
play man you didn't there that's it Wow
cool stuff pretty cool stuff ambitious I
like it anyway um
here it is sir it's in game over menu no
that's that must be the wrong one then
so play may need a biome is the one you
you're supposed to set I think just
search for that okay it's in main menu
as well there it is
so we'll say that - yep okay so get
about a thousand fps I mean there are
there aren't too many mobs here so this
is the old method by the way a thousand
I don't know if this will be any faster
actually because if there's only one mob
it shouldn't be slower there that's what
we're going for not slower
okay so it's about the same speed maybe
a little bit faster I was hitting 1150
1200 well actually inside them has to do
the calculation it's still pretty fast
actually I'd say overall it's a bit
faster you can see how nice that kind of
fade in isn't stuff it's quite nice I
mean obviously I could sit here and
tweak it and make it even better and
make it more perfect but I'm pretty
happy with the way this is cuz that's
not what this is about anyway
alright anyway it's gonna wrap up this
episode hope you guys enjoyed leave any
questions or concerns or thoughts in the
comments below
yeah don't forget to like the video as
well if you liked it next time I think
we'll cover maybe the actual mechanics
of the game such as the braiding
mechanic I don't know leave a comment in
fact in what you want to see next I'm
probably gonna start covering the logic
now because of the graphics have been
basically covered we fixed a bug which
is cool so the lighting bugs fixed now I
think I haven't tested it thoroughly but
I'm just kind of serious fixed you know
me but yeah leave a comment below with
what you want to see next as far as this
game goes but otherwise I think I want
to probably start covering the actual
game like the game flow maybe I'll start
off with maybe covering like all the
game states in the game floor and then
maybe move on to stuff like how the mobs
work and maybe how the like the entities
work and how the breeding works and all
that stuff I don't know we'll get to
that anyway thanks watching this episode
if you guys enjoyed place the like
button of course follow me on Twitter
link will be in description below and
I'll see you guys next time good bye
boom
you